العام الجديد لا يبدو مبشرا ايضا بالنسبه
للاقتصاد العالمي الذي يسير نحو الركود
تحذير جاء من صندوق النقد الدولي الذي
توقع ان يشهد الاقتصاد العالمي وركودا في
الربع الثالث من عام 2013
وقالت المديره صندوق النقد الدوليه
كريستالينا جورجيبا ان العام الجديد سيكون
صعب علي معظم اقتصاديات العالم واشارت
جورجينا الى ان الاقتصادات الرئيسيه
الثلاثه وهي الولايات المتحده والاتحاد
الاوروبيه والصين كلها تتباطؤ في وقت واحد
كما اضافت همم واضاف صندوق النقد الدولي
ان ازدياد حالات كورونا بالصين يحمل انباء
سيئه للاقتصاد العالميه على المدى القريه
توقعات صندوق النقد الدولي هذه تعزيز
التقارير التي صدرت ايام قبل نهايه العام
المنصرم والتي توقعت ركودا في العام
الجديد وكان مركز الاقتصاد والاعمال
البريطانيه قد توقع اي واجهه الاقتصاد
العالمي ركودا في 2023 بسبب ارتفاع تكاليف
الاقتراض التي تم اللجوء اليها لمواجهه
التضخم
[موسيقى]